I think in a normal situation if I would
have seen an Avenger walking down like
the hallway at Dodger Stadium I probably
would probably just would have been like
all right but there was definitely a
weird stalker moment where I felt weird
what's up I'm Blake I'm cute I'm Shaun
and we're gonna be telling you our
rejection horror stories mine is really
bad real bad there's a little bit of a
backstory of this one I was with my good
buddy Q and I had gotten us amazing
seats to the Dodgers game eight rows
back right between home plate and the
Dodgers dugout fantastic so I win got us
a little bottle of Jameson we took five
shots each and drank three beers before
we left we get there we're drunk we
immediately go we grab another tallboy
beer he grabs two Dodger dogs and then
proceeds to put a bunch of mustard and
ketchup combo just two times okay so
then who do I see Tessa Thompson looks
gorgeous she's wearing this like long
leather coat oh my gosh right I think in
a normal situation if I would have seen
an Avenger walking down like the hallway
at Dodger Stadium I probably would
probably just would've been like all
right but a little drunk I'm like we can
do this let's go holla at Tessa Thompson
by the way I had he has no idea lutessa
Thompson I'm just like no clue okay and
then he's saying how do you know it's
her how do you know it's her so I'm like
well hold on so we start kind of [ __ ]
I think following is it's not really
falling it's really quick it was quick
but there was definitely a weird stalker
moment where I felt weird and I was like
dude we shouldn't be doing this anyway
so I walk up we say hey what's going on
and then both of her and her and her
friend turned around like hey they were
not against us
talking to him they were like impressed
me and I start to stammer like I start
to just be and Hugh saves me kind of
yeah it really super kinda like I really
just he goes he says you're really
famous but I don't know who you are
Avengers end game had just came out okay
well check it out see other than not
like Valkyrie so immediately I try to
like save that and I go oh no no she's
an Avenger and she goes what other movie
in Miami right and this is where he just
and I should have said Crete sure
because I knew she was in Crete but for
some reason I blanked and I had to think
of something I just was set to get down
she's bi and she walks away and we're
just like okay honestly that went how we
thought it was gonna go but this is the
real best part of the story we realized
that Q when he had gotten those big
giant dodge dogs he had put these
beautiful dreadlocks he's paint brushed
his shirt with ketchup and mustard
you're like upside-down rainbow just
like ketchup and mustard rainbow all
beautiful tested Thompson just doodoo
Busey you learn my ketchup shirt it was
not good super embarrassing I tried to
make a joke out of it for like a week it
embarrassed me so much she really really
rejected us and um I just wanna say
sorry Tessa Thompson yeah we're really
sorry yeah I'm Blake in uh that was my
most horrific rejection ever by far
[Music]
what's up guys my name is Q and I'm
gonna tell you my dating horror story
scarred me for life actually really no
and that's enough for life but I was
definitely pretty hurt all right so
check it we're going back to high school
this is like sophomore year and I'm a
different type of guy I was a sweet
lover boy like my heart was just made of
gold and I had this girlfriend that I
was really loving like I've like really
loved her to death she was really dope
young wait yes miss wifey you know I'm
1516 I'm like yo man I might put a ring
on it what's your ring size
what's your wrist I'm like I know you
can be the one like just give me like a
little bit to put my money together we
gonna make it work that's I left
practice 15 you come out getting your
money together like that I wasn't saying
that but that's how I was feeling
okay oh okay but in my heart I'm like yo
so the thing was if my day was going so
good until I realized that you know it's
been like four hours I haven't heard
from my girlfriend in a minute after
practice she got it from her house phone
she's like yo my phone got stolen
earlier I was at this grocery store and
I sat it up on the thing real quick like
a little counter and somebody stole it
when I wasn't looking
I'm just like damn now
sucks like what's going on so we hang up
after a little while and I get a text
from our phone I'm like this is it like
somebody like texting me now look at the
message it was like yo bro what's up and
I'm just like I like whose text me from
her phone that I know somebody stole her
phone do you gotta mean the other dude
oh yeah it was definitely a dude listen
he's like yo what's up and I'm like yo
what's up like who is this he's like yo
don't worry about that I'm like
obviously yeah my heart so he s he
beckons like yo I got something to tell
you I'm just like all right what's up yo
yo your girl is cheating on you and I
just like wait like what
where's the proof you're lying to 16
year-old Q just crying bro
I was sick like I literally walked
outside like I was mad my MA was here
she's like what's wrong so like I'm
pissed I caught her and I walked outside
I'm like what's going play somebody just
text me and tell me you seen AMI and I'm
just like tripping out comes to find out
like the person was actually real like
if somebody stole her phone and look
through her phone and messages and saw
her texting like a bunch of other dudes
and just saw her like I'm like it's like
I love you babe good night yes so he so
he read it was like oh clearly this is
like your boyfriend so this guy that
stole the star cell phone is being a
humanitarian yeah that's what I was
buying later you know that your chick is
being unfaithful yes he's like I'm about
to go sell this phone real quick but
before I do
nice yes literally I want you to know
she's cheating yes so she does he send
you pictures or anything of like nah bro
this is this wasn't that time through
its nice okay so what kind of phones we
talking about
razors I like a sidekick do you know I'm
saying like we're not taking screams Oh
what oh you know what a sidekick is he
psychics were clones they were kind of
like Palm Pilots his friends mesme Oh
what uh and they would flip up and they
have a fool keep putting in another
little slide and he had a flip I like
the one flip it was some of the most
living everyone but besides the point I
put my sidekick he test him like Oh Dan
if she ever admit to you that she
doing this after a minute she's like I
was a sophomore you bro and this was his
wifey this is the [ __ ] he was like I'm
gonna get a ring with multiple dudes
cheating so honestly like the more Lewis
story like I was really hurt but I will
say like I'm kind of like thankful for
it because like God was looking out for
me cuz he's like yeah bro you don't need
this shake you falling in love too deep
and imma let you know by any means
necessary breasts telephone broken heart
is okay but he was like listen I need to
balance our caramel ooh yes no honestly
bless his heart but I promise you she
didn't need that phone anyway she did do
the cheater it wasn't his sidekick it
was when it was in the chocolate so it
wasn't cool dude chocolates Oh what you
and I she's bro I'm cute again and that
was my horrible dating force but you
should send a message to your little
Robin for those relationships yo bro I
really appreciate you like shout out you
know shot do you hit me up on Instagram
feel more phones hi my name is Shawn and
this is my worst rejection story alright
so this story takes place back in high
school
we're gonna call this girl Megan because
this girl is actually real I would hope
she would so this girl named Megan and I
was crushing on this girl all throughout
high school and I never had a chance to
talk to her just you know how never talk
to her you know how high school you like
get placed in classes I never got placed
in the class with it so three years go
by and as senior year comes around I
joined the high school newspaper team
and guess who's also in this class make
it did you joy because he was on the
team did you anyway anyway so I mean I'm
in newspaper you know it's an everyday
class so I see Megan every day and like
I just kept trying talks where I
couldn't I couldn't do it and then
eventually what happened was I friends
we're also friends amazing and through
them I found out that she likes a lot of
same hip-hop artists I do and one of her
biggest was Kanye West so this is 2013
back when he was still pretty tolerable
and he just released the easel
very stuck on a button very stuffed on I
mean it blows my mind did you listen to
it yeah
oh good album after he released Jesus he
was gonna go on tour and thing was I
found out about this information after I
already bought tickets so I already have
I think it's for her no I did not
so I had two tickets already bought
before this Jesus George you gotta
believe me hit and thing was I was
planning on going my friend but then
once I had this idea I had to tell my
Fred hey I need that ticket okay so here
was the plan the plan was I always got
to basically pull off a mission where I
was gonna take her on the first date to
a Kanye West concert this was about to
be the greatest thing ever
yeah so are you all my friends we starts
operation you know ask Megan out and
what it eventually became was like a
whole prom total type event so you're
like oh so this will happen so back in
high school Megan was the president of
this environmental Club and they meet
every Thursday's after school and what
they would do is they would take the
trash cans and go around and like pick
garbage out and do that kind of stuff
right so concert is November 21st so
November 14 2013 I have everything ready
I show up to school with a huge poster
that says Megan Kanye concert question
mark Sean right and I'm waiting at the
cafeteria after school well I have I
have my people playing right so I have
two people who joined the club just to
just to let me know like what the status
of Megan was and all the stuff I look
out I've no weird cuz we followed that's
a Thompson for like please I look
outside agents I have everything right
so plan was after school I'm waiting in
the cafeteria with this sign and she
will come get the trash cans and I would
be there ask her out and go to the
concert rest is history
I'm waiting five minutes go by no-show
10 miss go by no-show 30 minutes go by
and I'm still sitting there with this
poster right and I get a call from my
friend and he's like yo I have something
to tell you and I was like hey what's
what's going on like where's Megan he's
like oh yeah Megan left and I was like
what do you mean Megan left so
apparently there was a mole in my
operation and they snitched on me before
this happened and maybe you remember
waiting yeah so she knew about this Oh
surrounding a tummy no she just went
home she's ghost is you for real ghost
the next day I find out that a picture
of me holding the poster ended up on
Twitter so everyone in school
oh my everyone is like it was not even a
secret everyone knew about this yeah and
then the worst part was it's like a
class so I see her every day for the
rest of the school okay so let me get to
that part so don't tell me your friend
that you dubbed for the concert was the
one that was the mole
I've actually never thought about that
well but now I have to text some people
after after this year good idea okay so
here's what happen after words it's a
week until the concert I don't even want
to go anymore so I sell my two tickets
just to friends who I knew would
probably have a good time there Kanye
fans so this is high school I don't have
a lot of money so I bought like some
janky tickets high up in the nose please
not good seats right after the concert
you know I'm still weighing really down
after all the facets the two friends
were up to me right and this is the day
after the concert and I'm assuming it's
to tell me like how I went and the first
thing they say is you know that concert
was amazing hey did you know your seats
got upgraded to platinum
oh so you were like so they show me
videos of them like right behind the
front row Wow living it up at this Kanye
concert yeah
oh my god could be you and Megan well
guess what you know who the real loser
is me yeah Megan is a close second yeah
that story little epic you're a strong
man and that was my worst rejection
story
[Music]